[Music]
that for me was probably the most
intense
experience i had reporting in america
i think everyone who worked there and
reported on it was affected by it
[Music]
it was something else it really
you know young kids it just hit home for
me personally
and colleagues with children really
really
struck them
the first reports coming in were a
couple of
children had been shot and a school
teacher had been injured
you have everyone in the classroom in
the door all of my students the door's
not locked yet
there's reports of a government reports
of children going to hospital
and obviously that that sort of sense of
dread
because it was an elementary school
they've been shootings in schools in
america
but not in elementary schools or primary
schools and i think that's what made us
realize very early on this was going to
be very different
mass shooting a gunman on the loose in a
primary school
was going to be an even worse kind of
incident than we'd
been used to an american before
bodies here i went home and packed a bag
and raced back in and in the 20 minutes
i was gone it had gone from
a couple of children shot and a school
teacher injured to
at that point it was almost 20 i think
they had almost come to the 20
shot dead it was a look on my producer's
face at the time when i came back with
you know
the sheer horror the advice
we should have multiple weapons
including one rifle
we flew up there as soon as we could and
we were up there late evening
and to give you an idea in those just a
few hours every
network news crew in the area had got
there
all the big networks were there and
there was a sort of forest of lights and
cameras outside this building
where just a few hours earlier parents
have been gathered and they've been told
some of them that their kids weren't
coming home
[Music]
it's obviously a horrific event but
you've got to try and
show what's happening but you've also
got to be respectful of what's
what's occurred
[Music]
by the time we got there gordon was back
a bit it was difficult to
talk to people up close initially anyway
people were already laying flowers some
people would put out makeshift signs
there was grief and people responding to
the grief all around us
[Music]
people over and over again would say
this doesn't happen here this is such a
small town this sort of thing just
doesn't happen
i guess it's like you know if it
happened in my hometown i would probably
feel the same it's
clearly it's a horrific event
another friend of mine said that um
there was a man a masked man came in and
just started shooting
americans have a real more than anyone
in the world they have a real
duty they feel a sense of duty that they
should talk to
the cameras whenever they can so in the
few hours after the shooting
you had children in the car park at this
school being interviewed by
tv crews i was in the gym and i heard a
loud
well i heard like seven loud booms you
know six-year-olds seven-year-olds
talking about what they've been through
every door in the building
except for the ones in the hallway had
the clothes
and they were saying the same things as
you've seen teenagers and adults
americans say after shootings but these
were these were young kids i saw some of
the bullets
going past the hall that i was right
next to
then a teacher pulled me into her
[Music]
class
[Music]
my daughter emily
would be one of the first ones to be
standing and giving her love and support
to all those victims
because that's the type of person that
she is there was one dad he spoke
literally the day after it happened i
think and he he wanted to say
he wanted to tell the world how amazing
his daughter was and um
and how lucky he was to have had her not
because of any parenting that my wife
and i could have done
but because those are the gifts that
were given to her by her heavenly father
i mean struck you know how incredibly
brave that was and i think it's part of
this american tradition of
with this feeling that you you you have
to bear witness to what's happened
you have to say what's happened and so
it has an effect
on the future but also because you want
people to know what your daughter is
like
in the middle of the town centre there
was a christmas tree because this was
just a few weeks before christmas
and this christmas tree became a shrine
people came from miles around sort of as
a pilgrimage
to i guess express their solidarity and
grief with what had happened in the town
and so we interviewed these people as
they came
it's time for change
this is i'm left speechless
it's shocking it's appalling
this one lady had driven up from new
york what made you come up here
um i don't know i guess i didn't really
know what to expect or
what i was going to see more so just to
just to um i guess
see if there was anything that could be
done
but all you can do is talk to people
and pass out hugs
[Music]
and dominic i remember asking her you
know why are you so sad
she couldn't explain why she came but
she felt she needed to
and uh you know i teared up and and it's
difficult to listen to what these people
were saying you know she had no
connection with anyone
she just felt she had to be there it's
just overwhelmingly sad
you shouldn't put your child on a school
bus
in the morning and never see them again
or drop them off at school
and never see them again
[Music]
i remember the day after we arrived
there was a librarian
giving a press conference in one of the
car parts near the school
she also felt that she had to come out
and say what had happened to her we
started hearing the gunshots so
i yelled locked down to the group that
was in our room and i ran across the
hall and
told the classroom across from us to
lockdown i remember thinking
this is a country where children age
five six and seven
are all of them they're all routinely
drilled
to go through a lockdown procedure
because of the possibility
of a gunman coming to their school and
shooting them
and this is a country where that's
normal and this is a country where i'm
bringing him up bringing up my children
for a few years who also trained at
school
about the possibility of a government
coming in and shooting them all
and they have to process that and not
just
train for that and process it but also
accept that as normal that's a normal
part of life
and thinking what is that doing to all
these children but also what's it doing
to my children
[Music]
people are professional they deal with
horrific events
constantly but it was one of those where
20 very young school children were
murdered so
if you've got children of that age you
can imagine
how how difficult that would have been
actually to report on the events the
families of the dead now face the ordeal
of their funerals some of them starting
here
as early as tomorrow i think as a
journalist you're presented all the time
with
terrible situations that make no sense
you have to develop a kind of
professional detachment
so you can carry on doing a job
reporting on it for me
sandy hook was the biggest challenge to
that it was the hardest job
keeping your detachment
and i think what always strikes you as a
parent is when you get reminded of your
own children
what really hits home when you're
covering the news is when someone is
affected who reminds you of you
and you think your children aren't that
different in age and these were 20
kids aged six and seven
you do almost have to shut it off
because that's just one way of dealing
with it
[Music]
you can talk to your friends about some
stuff but you almost
take a step back
if you're too involved in what's going
on you
become emotionally involved if there's
even one step
we can take to save another child then
surely we have an obligation to try
there were growing calls for changes for
gun control for things to happen
are we really prepared to say that we're
powerless
in the face of such carnage
that's what makes makes it even more
depressing it didn't actually lead to
any change
it is a very different country it's a
very different attitude to guns
for historical reasons for cultural
reasons it's enshrined in the
constitution
one american said to me you know the
chance to drive a car is a privilege
the chance to buy and own a gun is a
god-given right
no man can take that away and that
gives you a very strong sense of how
embedded it is in their constitution but
their culture
and the history
if you own a gun you're not going to
give it up easily you know there's talk
of
legislating bullets you know keep your
guns but actually you've got to
register bullets and that might actually
have an effect but
it's a political mind field
we interviewed a 17 year old teenager
and just a few days after
so many children be gunned down he was
absolutely insistent there should be no
change
to gun laws in america it's the second
amendment the constitution you can't
just
change that i mean it's a right we all
have and we deserve to have it
we need guns because there's a
possibility of
tyranny returning there's a possibility
of the british coming back
so they're brought up with this historic
sense that they have to be able to have
guns for their own good for their own
protection
[Music]
frankly if 20 school children and their
teachers being murdered doesn't
make you want to change the gun laws and
nothing will
the constitutional right to own a gun is
sacrosanct and
nothing nothing really will change that
[Music]
throughout the aftermath of san diego
these feelings amongst all of us i hope
that it could lead to a change so these
insane
situations don't happen again but also
kind of gnawing sense of dread which was
that
if that didn't lead to anything you'd
end up in an even worse situation
that if the killing of 20 children aged
six and seven didn't lead to change
then america probably would give up hope
i don't that's happened yet
but i think um there is still a sense
that if that didn't change it nothing
will
[Music]